let's do a few audience questions first
one is from Brett Brett said David what
is your book on your view on reading I
know you sometimes recommend books but
do you look down at people who don't
read what are the benefits of reading
should everybody read how much do you
read I think it will come as no surprise
particularly to those who emailed me and
say that I am a an elitist when it comes
to reading by by which I guess they mean
I read yes I think that reading is
absolutely fantastic reading number one
when if whether you're talking about
fiction or nonfiction it doesn't matter
regular reading number one helps to
expand the ways in which we are able to
understand and sort of integrate
information into our minds reading
long-form books compared to reading
articles on news sites for example
really allows for the building of a more
nuanced understanding of issues that
even reading a whole bunch of sequential
articles on a topic doesn't allow you to
do with regard to vocabulary we know
from studies done on little kids little
kids who were read to by the time they
get to first grade have drastically
larger vocabularies than kids who are
not and this is something that you it's
very difficult it is a lot of work to
get caught up if you have a vocabulary
deficiency at that early point in life
later on and I think everybody should
read how much do I read not enough not
as much as I would like I mean as far as
fiction goes I read fiction every night
before going to bed
depending on how tired I am that might
be 30 to 40 minutes or it might be five
minutes if I'm particularly tired and I
love reading fiction and I recommend
that a lot of those books as far as
nonfiction I try to I have two moments
in the day where I try to get some
nonfiction reading in one is first thing
in the morning when I wake up once I get
started with my day and the show and
production and all these different
things it can often become very
difficult to squeeze in more time to
read nonfiction and I don't like reading
nonfiction before going to bed I find it
sort of wakes me up so first thing in
the morning while I'm having breakfast
is often when I will read nonfiction
and then the other opportunity is
sometimes mixed in with you know like
after work before after going to the gym
or something like that I will try to
read some nonfiction I would really like
to be reading more nonfiction Pat yeah I
mean that's a fantastic habit to be
getting into honestly since I've left
college I haven't been doing too much
reading but I'm considering getting an
audible subscription because I like the
idea of being able to lie in bed closing
my eyes and listening to a story driving
around in the car at the gym I think
that would just be more it would be more
conducive to my lifestyle we've heard
from an expert on I don't remember
exactly what he was an expert on in
terms of his profession but he said that
listening to books basically is almost
identical for the brain as reading books
with some differences that we don't know
a lot on but in terms of understanding
the information and adding to knowledge
etc it seems to be pretty close in terms
of the benefits yeah and for me just
staring at text for a long time I can
find can be pretty draining new and I
often feel like I'm just trying to rush
through chapters and get through the
pages but when I listen to a book I can
really just enjoy it for what it is
interesting yeah so yeah I I don't know
what else I could say about this and I
you find it very interesting that I've
been around different little kids lately
like two three four years old every
single one of them regardless of the
sort of education level of their parents
regardless of the socio-economic level
of their parents they love books books
are toys that little kids love and it's
interesting how so many people get out
of the habit of reading once they are no
longer little kids and they start
playing other types of toys it seems to
me that you can really create a love of
reading and kids very early on because
I've never seen a two three or four year
old who doesn't love books and hearing
stories and looking at pictures and if
you continue that kids love reading and
they can love it and for me it continued
straight through and with media what it
is today if there's TV and computers and
tablets and phones it's a good sign that
kids are still enjoying reading that's
very important no doubt about it sorry
I'm big on reading and check out a lot
of my book recommendations at david
pakman.com slash recommendations i know
that there are lots of people in the
anti-intellectual n't who really don't
understand the
of reading oh boy reading that sounds
like bogus philosophy for lefties I'm
not going to get involved in that at all
and that's absolutely horrible